first of all interesting that and I
understand you but when you were on
Adam's sauce next podcast
you were very adamant on not being part
of the manosphere
so kind of if you don't mind going into
a little bit of that in terms of why you
you've kind of disassociated yourself
from that
um so I never really tried to associate
with it to begin with you know if I can
be perfectly honest I I started
uploading videos in 2014
and the term manager wasn't introduced
to me until I started talking to role of
tomasi right uh prior to that it was
like
like mgtow videos you know
um and they were actually good mgtab
videos at the time like 2016 2017 that's
when I started talking about stuff
around relationships and divorce and you
know the realities of the world and that
sort of stuff and I didn't really know
what the manuscript was I was just
answering questions that my audience
wanted to hear some uh you know
discussion on and I think around that
time one of the channels that I was
watching more of was uh I think was
mgtow 101 or M M towel like 101 or
something like this I think he was a
South African or Australian guy he's one
of those faceless dudes that sort of
just like did voice over commentary on
um press pieces uh interviews
um and sort of just said you know this
is what's going on and you know this is
why it happened sort of thing and it
would offer a little bit of context
around it and they were generally pretty
good they weren't anti-women or pro-male
or anything they were just like you know
these are reality of the world sort of
thing
um and then I kind of got sucked into uh
the whole manisphere when I started to
get interested in
um stuff like the rational mail and then
there was other people that sort of came
with that pickup artists
um dating coaches
um all these guys and that was never me
um I've always been an entrepreneur I
ran a very successful business for
decades
um you know I haven't worked for anybody
since 2002 I don't think
so when I got pulled into that it was a
lot of oh okay so this guy has some good
information it seems like this guy has
some useful information
and um I started to promote them they
didn't have anything they were mostly
like people that were
Anonymous on Twitter
um on blogs you know stuff like that
they never really had a YouTube channel
I think at that time I had about 100 000
Subs
and um you know I bring them on my
channel and talk to them and we started
like group uh shows and one group show
you know ended because one of the guys
was a complete idiot in that uh realm of
thing so I pulled away from him and I
started working with other people and
when she starts spending time with these
guys that are manosphere creators the
reason why I call it the Mano swamp is
because generally speaking they're not
good men or they're not good at being
men in my estimation
um a lot of them are hypocrites they'll
tell you for example dating women that
have children from a prior relationship
is Bad News Bears but they will get into
and marry a single mom and lie about it
um they'll mock things uh you know for
example like one of the things that I've
um found very useful in my life was trt
uh testosterone replacement therapy and
then you'll see them a few years down
the road on trt you know there's a
significant change in their physique
um so a lot of these guys I don't see
them as good men or good at being men
and I'm I'm very protective of
the people that I hang around with and
people that I love and the people that I
want to spend time with the people that
I want to build up and if I don't see
you as a good man or good at being a man
and by the way if you want some more
context around that I think Jack
Donovan's books uh you know the way of
man becoming a barbarian these are
really really good reads for men that
want to learn about masculinity as it
really is not as the guys in the man of
swamp will try to tell you that it is
because again a lot of these guys are
hypocrites they aren't doing what they
say they're doing they've got very uh
how can I put this they've got shitty
pass you know like you wouldn't be proud
of their past being laid out at a table
if you're having dinner with your family
in front of your friends and family you
know for example so yeah I just decided
not to uh spend any more time with them
I mean I I speak on very similar topics
but I don't I don't encourage or endorse
much if any of their material anymore
just because the people and the way they
are they're not great friends you know
interesting okay I mean I don't care to
bless any names but I'm really curious
to know like I guess examples but
you know again they can either I don't
want to put any no I don't want to put
any names like blast it's just like this
there's no point in dealing with that
it's just again you know there's a lot
of people in that space and and it's
growing now like there's a lot of women
that have moved into that space so a lot
of people that are grifting in that
space and it's like
they see an opportunity to reach men
that are struggling but they're not guys
that have done much or any or anything
significant with their lives right they
have peppered past bankruptcies jails
incarcerations like [__] like getting
other people in jail believe it or not
um I've seen it all right so it's like I
just can't associate myself with people
that come from that level right
um I've worked too hard and I'm too good
of a person in my estimation and people
that know me personally to sit at the
same table with those guys I don't like
I want to see them eat you know I want
to see them survive I just don't want to
sit at the same table with them and
share a meal with them anymore if you
know what I mean so
um I wish them all the best and I just
don't want to be a part of it that's all
okay that's perfectly fine that's that's
yeah it's become very saturated and a
lot of people don't really
care about the
the intricacies of
understanding male and female Dynamics
they just want their views and I think
you know at the end of the day as a
content creator of course I want views
and I want the money that comes with it
but I care much more about the content
that I put out I was explaining this to
a friend a good friend of mine wasn't
talking to me about the algorithm you
know he's all he started a channel very
recently he's very very algorithm based
and I was saying listen man of course I
want to grow a big Channel but I'm not
interested in having some porn star on
my show just so I can get a million
views I really
it's not going to happen like I I want
my channel to have value and substance
and if that means that I have to I have
to push at it for 10 years whereas if I
would have had a bunch of women with
their tits out and that would have
gotten me there faster it's not it's
just not gonna happen I care much more
about doing what I feel makes sense yeah
I'm with you on that I mean you you you
came on my unplug Alpha podcast which is
a separate channel from the
entrepreneurs and cars it's really just
something that I do as a weekly show to
talk about [__] that I think that's
interesting and take Collins and I mean
I it's it's got 37 000 Subs which is not
bad for one year's worth of work
um but I also have another Channel I
have the book and I sort of send traffic
to it so there's so there's a little bit
of that you know momentum that that
picked up but I mean I could have easily
had three hundred thousand or three
million Subs had I you know taken the
red meat uh path which is get a bunch of
bimbos make them look bad you know on
the show and use clickbaity titles and
thumbnails for like clips and shorts and
stuff like that and
um it's not that I don't have you know
men and women that call in to show that
are like topics of conversation that we
cover that could be potentially looked
as clickbaity but I don't produce the
content thinking to myself okay gotcha
[__] like I want to set this up like I
get him in a gotcha [__] you know sort
of like clickbaity sort of like let's
make this into a short like I don't
build my stuff out like that I'd rather
do it more
organically having good conversations
and I kind of have that flexibility
because I don't need the money right
like I've I've been successful before I
started up YouTube right like I was
already a multi-millionaire long before
I even uploaded my first video so
um I don't need to to Pander to the
algorithms and do the red meat and make
the bimbos look bad on the show you know
sort of thing
um so that's why I do what I do the way
that I do it so I would encourage you to
do the same thing you know stay true to
the sorts of conversations topics that
you want to be on and don't feed the
[__] because there's too much of it
out there
Joe Rogan spoke about this on one of his
episodes a long time ago when he was
talking about how long it took him to
come up even though he had a name from
Fear Factor it's not his he wasn't a
nobody
I'm I'm a huge huge advocator of that if
if it's going to take me years until the
channel grows tremendously so be it but
I you know I compare it to to artists to
music artists say the you know the new
age rappers that stick around for three
years and no one knows who they are
afterward versus the rappers who've been
known for 10 20 30 40 years
there's a there I don't care to be the
new trend I care to be relevant for a
long time and actually put out
substantial content that's that's a lot
more valuable I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out